- So when I was a young kid
I made a lot of money selling
baseball cards and comic books
and toys and then I started
working for my dad's business
and I was making, you know,
when I was 22 to 28 I was making
$35-$55,000 a year
but I had no expenses.
I didn't go on vacations.
I didn't buy fancy things.
So I saved my money,
I save my money,
I save my money and
then when, you know,
I had hundreds of
thousands of dollars.
I didn't have millions.
And by the time I was 33, 34
when I had that opportunity
I'd still not bought a home.
I was still in an apartment.
I was 33 years old and I was
renting and because I was saving
cash to go on the offense.
And so when I had a chance
to invest in those companies,
I put hundreds of
thousands of dollars,
not millions but those
hundreds made millions,
made tens of
millions and so that's it.
Nothing crazy, nothing.
I didn't have any
crazy, crazy advantage.
There's a lot of people that
make $55,000
a year when they're 23.
The problem is they go to
Coachella and they want to
buy a watch and they want
to buy a BMW and I didn't.
So I ate shit for 13 years
and then I had a
moment and I struck.
(hip hop music)